- So I think I wanna
get something like navy.
Not anything too heavily patterned
because I think that's just
gonna make it look cheap.
(laughing)
Today we will be buying
suits off of Amazon.
Not soups, suits.
- I'm gonna try a men's suit
and maybe I'll fit into one.
I'm a little worried about a pants,
because men's pants they
don't cut for bum and hips,
which I have because I'm
created to birth children.
- So you actually know
more about suits than I do
because you made a video
where you got a suit, and it looked
very good on you.
- Thank you.
- So you've definitely
had more suit experience
than I have.
- I want patterns, colors.
- So I should try to
get a more normal suit.
- Let's go order our suits.
- Okay, fashion.
- Fashion.
- That's what we're here for.
So we've got a lot of Suits DVDs.
Here's Van Husen.
- $100.
- This is pants and jacket.
- And you can get it in two days.
- We got a yup, I found it.
This is like I'm selling
ice cream on the pier.
Dark green double breasted.
This is a party tuxedo for men.
That's exactly what I need.
I think I found my suit.
Your turn.
- So I would love some pattern.
That's too much.
- We'll leave a trail of
sequence wherever we go.
- No one will look good
in this, I don't think.
The thing with floral print
is, is it cute or is it ugly?
It's very hard to find an in between.
- That one.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- All right.
I will add it to cart.
I'm gonna keep poking around.
I could look like a peacock conductor.
Annie, is this ugly or cute?
Do you like this one?
- I like the first one.
That's very vampire weekend.
- I do like vampire weekend.
- I kind of want to get
that peacock jacket.
- The one that I got?
- Yeah.
I think I'm just gonna steal yours.
This one doesn't actually
look like a peacock.
- Yes it absolutely does.
Do you like the red one
and I'll get the black one.
- I kind of want us to
both have the red one.
Should the exciting suits go well,
it'll be the most--
- sha-bang.
- Explosive display of clothing ever.
- It's like Christmas.
Merry Christmas from the Amazon fairy.
- I see a sequin.
- Don't people like unboxing videos.
- Is this doing it for ya.
- This is my sequent peacock.
- Nice bag.
Oh dear, oh god.
- Shinier than I thought it would be.
Oh, the lining though.
Nice.
- This is an extra small.
Oh my god, what? What?
- Hold them up for.
- I can put this over my clothes
and it would still be too big.
This is an extra small.
- Is the rest of this video
us going to clown college.
There's some more stuff in the bag here.
- Oh good, a cummerbund.
There's also a bow tie.
- Oh yeah.
- I do fit into men's suits, I do.
But this is bonkers.
It's like in Little Rascal's
where they sit on top
of each other and try to go to the bank.
- Maybe the peacock distracts
from the ill-fitting nature
of the suit.
- Really?
I'm very disappointed.
We measured, too.
You know how everything in the
90s was three times too big.
Oh god.
I'm curious to see how it's gonna fit you
because you got one size up from this.
Yeah that's your, bud.
Those are your pants.
- Here are my pants.
They might be okay.
Yeah these are actually too tight on me.
- Here you go cummerbund.
- Cue Benedict Cummberbund.
I mean, this isn't supposed
to go over a t-shirt.
- Amazing.
- It actually fits me.
Look at this stuff.
- Is that supposed to flap off like that?
- It's definitely tight.
- Yours is a size bigger than mine.
This is so weird to me.
- There's jewels though.
- Bejeweled.
- With the t-shirt, I look fully like--
- [Niki] Maybe a stripper.
- [Andrew] A magician stripper.
Are there any magician strippers?
- Let's try the other ones.
Maybe we'll have better luck.
Maybe I'll have better luck.
You seem to be fine.
Okay go.
Yeah these are definitely better.
This at least kind of fits.
- One thing I notice is that
these buttons don't fit through
the button holes.
- What?
- Try to get that through there.
- They don't fit, your buttons
don't fit through the hole.
What?
- Like what are these for?
- I mean, it's double breasted.
- These pretty much nail
my nipples, by the way.
- You look very businessman-ish.
This color is nice on you.
The colors on the website made this look
much more bold than it actually is.
These are pretty muted colors.
Like I can't walk normally in this suit.
I should just always be dancing.
- I feel like I want to
check a pocket watch.
- Oh you got your button to work.
- Yeah, I just jammed it through.
- See that, you look relatively charming.
You look charming.
Also, why is there a tag on
the outside of your pants?
- Oh, the medium is on
the outside of my pants.
That's just to let people know.
- I mean, we did pay
like 80 bucks for a suit,
which is like, good suits
can range up to like $1000.
So for $80 I have a suit that fits.
- I think suits are often
taken a little too seriously.
This is like a very fun
approach to suit wearing.
- If you need to look
like a cop for Halloween,
you've nailed it.
A detective.
- Yeah.
What do you think?
- [Niki] I'll take that as a yes.